we were backstage with the ladies before
their big show including model mama
the hotty Prinsloo who has her hubby
Adam Levine to thank for her healthy
motivation he is a special person that
guy he's such a workout junkie he's so
full of energy sometimes I'm like I
can't do this video I think you can
looks like Adams been be hotties
personal trainer getting her ready for
tonight's runway the 30 year old just
had her second child barely nine months
ago after kids you'll must feel stronger
you want to do it more you want to prove
more I'm just so proud and I have two
girls at home I mean it's crazy I could
cry Adam will be in the audience
cheering on his angel but the tables
will be turned when maroon 5 performs
the Super Bowl halftime show in February
I'm his number one fan so wherever he is
I'm there
Shawn Mendes will be among tonight's
performers as the models finished
getting glam
kendall Jenner got some early practice
but her sisters when they got lingerie
and wings as Halloween costumes and it
seems bella and gigi hadid have been
preparing for this moment since they
were kids
mom Yolanda posted this shot from 18
years ago bella is such a blessing for
me as a friend and a sister and for
Adriana Lima tonight will be a first for
six and eight year old girls will be
watching I felt like more beautiful
after I gave birth to my two daughters I
hope I will make them happy Adriana
always gets the crowd going with she
walks on that runway good luck tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]